[Music]
guys Rainbow six siege is a tactical
shooter that takes an immense amount of
skill discipline and awareness to play
at the highest level and if you do that
better than Penghu already a giant in
the scene this player has accomplished
so much in just a short amount of time
and shows no signs of slowing down just
yet
so sit back and enjoy as we bring you
the top ten moments that Penghu proved
he was legendary kicking off our list is
a play from this year's six Invitational
Pangu and canto were tasked with a 2v2
retake against mantas FPS and after a
quick double spray down from Pangu canto
went on to disable the diffuser and end
the match but Pangu didn't want him to
take any credit attempting to get the
diffuse down but there's a jump n V
Taylor cuts down fabien and it's a
successful plant but tanku the heroics
takes out heady takes out and V Taylor
and it will be an easy disabled as
Penghu gets all the glory and we'll move
to map 2 with G 2 winning 8 to 6 but as
close as it gets there ladies and
gentlemen but G to persevere coming in
at the number 9 spot is a year two
season to play from a match against
supremacy staring down a 1v3 situation
on Blackbeard Pangu managed to claw his
way back into the round and get the
defuser down there was just one problem
the Dane ran out of bullets
as the valkyrie reloaded Penghu whipped
out the deagle swung wide and dropped
his opponent in style we're gonna have
two members from pencil left alive KS
falls Penghu has repelled on inside he's
now a corner office with defuser going
up against three members from the
different two members from the defending
squad
there's the seaport ah Seto he talks it
too far I don't think people who knew
that he's that close and there it is
Pinker taking out one can he take out
the other he knows Poseidon was inside
of cubby work Lily's close to there he's
moved on to the other palm side don't
for the plant beside it now he's gonna
try to rush on over he's go for the kill
it doesn't work out in pink who now
knows exactly where he's at
who's gonna get the first kill you don't
for the deagle kill can he get it
Pingu dropping the clutch right there's
beside they will fall to the 50 caliber
bullet going into his chest
tegus [ __ ] instinct he's insane
taking the number 8 spot on our list is
a play from last year's six invitational
in the opening round against NC esports
Penta were stuck in a 2v5 situation with
over a minute left on the clock Pangos
mera managed to hold the bomb site and
stop the plant and against the remaining
attacker the Danish superstar expertly
danced around the bomb to clutch at the
round but he's depending entirely on
Pegu downstairs to hold fight yeah the
mirrors got the c4 in the vector but
good luck holding against the five man
strong attack with King not to mention
the little phone call that could come
out last minute there from Wilkie gonna
hit right in here goes in for the twitch
drops her down and there we go canto
will fall as well as Pahadi Pengo will
get the c4 off from down below bones
he's trying to move in with a t95 spring
in with the yang as he goes in 1v1
versus the mirror and that's where panco
will shine taking him out Pangu and
Fabian both speaking taking down to the
future
Kuno is down his somehow then turns into
a 2v1 Wilkie all on his own get still
number one now down to one b1 Penghu is
right up behind now just using a be to
his advantage as he picks up season 75
has a pretty good rate of fire to go for
the aggression here mk14 pulled up hey
[ __ ] at Banco Launceston 101 and
what an explosive first round Penta
coming in at number seven is yet another
play from the 2018 six invitational down
a map against evil geniuses in the grand
final Penta were looking to make a
comeback and with the player downed on
each side Pangu was essentially left in
a 1v2 to tie up the rounds they're gonna
hope that n BK can cover he'll get one
and BK manages a stick and PC gets
defuser down SBC takes out Bobby and
before Penghu eliminates and BK it's 2-2
in neck rocks has been down on the
stairs as well as shot a who's been down
as well so we'll come down to the mirror
battling against the buck on the line
here is the potential or
G to be able to go to series point you
can hear the beer coming down but Penta
will win this one BC Falls Penghu plays
that smart and we will have an 11 Brown
for the number 6 spot on our list is yet
another play from pentas match against
NC sports at the 2018 six Invitational
quarterfinals as the attackers were
planting the diffusor Penghu lobbed a
beautiful c4 to take out two enemies and
ended the round with a sweet 4k b smoke
now the future will get sexy for
throwing out and killing a triple from
Pengo here we go Penta in full control
of 401 I've got a I got a new strat for
fence when they're attacking basement
kill Pangu first that's that's the strap
that will actually win this doesn't
matter who else you kill if you don't
kill Pangu first it's over on that
attack at the midway point on our list
is a 3k from the paris major we're Pangu
was holding down the CEO office on
Castle against team secret after denying
some of the ex Cairo's pellets with an
impact grenade the Habano is forced to
take a bad bite on the floor and to add
insult to injury
Pangu took full advantage of the created
crawl space to take out the unsuspecting
attackers and here we go possibly going
for a look at that steezy
tries to go for me stretch to go for the
crawl in deposit we take out Penghu
playing on a very interesting position
perched atop that bomb defuser will be
picked up a coca will take his own fight
just by a janitorial closet that coach
drove from his teammate will help but
look at this now peg you're working out
get it go with another yes
just as you said g2 needed to witness
they'll get it and we'll head to the
second half with secret up Laurita two
absolutely beautiful place there from
Penghu coming in at number four on our
list is an epic 4k from the 2019 six
Invitational semi-final after g2 esports
took full control of the armory bomb
site against team reciprocity Pangu was
able to cover his team with a quick
triple kill
leaving the pulse in an impossible one v
2 as g2 has whole site control and that
smoke is beautiful as g2 is just in
right now ready to lob a frag grenade
all the way back catch but he doesn't
get it
mangu takes down skies it's a trade
secret goes out caught by Penghu Fabien
Falls Penghu doing so much work right
now he's got every kill except for one
for his team on this round the mark is
currently being isolated himself in the
site there's so many marks for him to go
in pardon the pot of 4k by Penghu what a
play on attack g2 just takes clubhouse
forward to two that's not how things are
supposed to go on this site and on this
map we're taking you all the way back to
pro league year two season two semi
finals for our number three entry Penta
were up against team font and despite
winning the first map
Pangu had an abysmal performance but the
date was quick to turn things around and
after a beautiful shot through the kids
room window Penghu swung in to the site
to gun down the remaining defenders in
quick succession still gonna be hiding
in the bathroom yeah there oh oh here we
go
Pangu sprays and finally gets to kill me
all right camera down Maringa right
behind the wall and Penghu is just gonna
be waiting around they don't have to
peek this too much just I wait until it
gets in the crossfire and Peggle gets
one
and pendel codes this is the Pengo we
know that that's the pay you are - that
justifies that pick so nicely done by
Pangu shown why he's playing it that way
our runner-up spot goes to the gabe
winning play of the 2018 six
invitational that's right it's the time
Pangu clutched out a 1v2
against evil geniuses to win it all eg
were looking to tie up the match after
Penta planted the diffusor as the two
teams trade kills but Pangu crushed the
North American dream completing the
reverse sweep to win our sixes coveted
trophy now look to push together the
defuser in a position where they'll have
to see when the Habano goes through one
will cover the doorway they start taking
the number one spot on our list is the
game-winning play of the semi-finals
against team font during year two season
2 of pro league honestly we could have
made an entire list of plays from just
this game alone and saying Pangu popped
off would be an understatement
seriously just sit back and watch Pangu
close out the match with a 4k ending the
map with a record-breaking 21 kills
winds it up no no then here we go Panda
gentlemen are going to the grand final
are we gonna see a repeat of last year
well it's not gonna be head to vs the
Brazilians this time well guys that's
all for this week now if you want to see
us do a top 10 around your favorite
Rainbow six siege player let us know who
that is in the comment section and we'll
make it happen thanks for watching if
you want more great content just like
this be sure to hit the subscribe button
[Music]
you
[Music]